I was wondering how much I plan to charge
for life.
I am going to confess,
I have not set myself 1 salary of €8 500,
I'm going to wear it out of 30,000.
And what's more,
for 2 lives,
for this one and for the next one I will have a salary
just in case for the future.
As if it were 1 person of we can
and once it has been released,
it continues to be paid by the public.
Look,
they have invented the hoax of the week with 1 salary
who already know how much it's going to be,
when it is 1 law that is not,
is 1 rule
that has not even begun to be drafted
when the presidents of the Community of Madrid
are among the few in Spain
who do not even have 1 dwelling during the office,
as all his bosses in government do,
22 ministries: How many houses do we Spaniards pay for?